sometime around the last quarter moon we
typically see these large groups of
turtles forming offshore and essentially
wait for some cue it's like they're all
out there kind of wait for it wait for
it at some point hundreds of thousands
of Turtles start to emerge from the
shore
each individual turtle is slowly gonna
crawl up the shore and fight her way to
find a spot to lay her nests
Austan al is really unique because this
happens almost every month of the year
in very large numbers on this three
kilometer stretch of beach in three or
four days so it's a lot of turtles and
not a lot of space
in us now we might get 500,000 turtles
into seven days in each turtle lays a
hundred eggs and that's how many
hatchlings are coming off of this beach
and a lot of those eggs are just getting
destroyed by the same turtles themselves
for a lot of people who love sea turtles
it's very hard to accept the legal take
of turtle eggs because they don't
understand what that looks like that's
why this was legalized in the first
place
that's why the scientists justified it
because if you're not there and you
don't see what the town is like and what
what the beach looks like then it's
really hard to accept saying okay take
this endangered species eggs I like
Austin all because it's a really quiet
place and people is very friendly and
especially we have a lot of turtles
normally they have to count the turtles
and they can represent one we have more
than 2000 euros
the job from the Association is to
support the community 70% of the money
is for the people that is working in the
exhibition the other 30% is to pay the
patrols and also pay the geology guys
some of the money to protect community
in general by the schools I think the
community's working pretty well they
really love the trails and that's why
they are still doing this before this
harvest was made legal it was a
free-for-all
most beaches if any turtle comes and
nests that nest gets taken so in Austin
al the egg harvest program pays for
guards to be on the beach all night
watching out for illegal poaching and
when it's not legal to be taking eggs I
mean those two now is arguably the
safest beach in Guanacaste while there's
a small percentage of eggs that are
taken and that's what most people are
opposed to if you really look at us you
know it's also a Wildlife Refuge that
has very little funding and resources to
protect it the egg harvest program gives
the community ownership of protecting
that Beach if you don't protect the
community of us Janel and keep an eye
out for their needs then you're not
protecting the turtles
you